What's not to
get nervous about?
It's the most terrifying
thing most people do--
is talking in public.
But remember that the
worst that can happen
is you might be a
little bit embarrassed.
And it can be fixed later.
I think the biggest
lessons I learned--
if you're dealing with bad
news, get it out quickly.
Just get it out there.
I've interviewed every
president, foreign leaders,
politicians, celebrities,
people from all walks of life.
But I think the lessons I've
learned can apply to all of you
in your conversations with
your friends and your family,
in your conversations
at the workplace.
And I'm privileged
to have the chance
to share what I've
learned with you.
We're going to take
a look back at some
of my most memorable
interviews--
some for good
reasons, some for bad.
And I hope that people will
be able to draw lessons
that they can apply
to their own lives,
how to be both
honest and sensitive,
but how to have hard
conversations, how
to be confrontational
without being a jerk.
In the workplace, nothing is
more important than preparation
before communicating.
If you don't know what you're
talking about, you can't talk.
Back in 2006, I was interviewing
President George W. Bush.
I had the manifestations
of a panic attack.
I was in full flop sweat
in front of the President
of the United States.
I was absolutely mortified.
And what I learned
by making mistakes
is that whatever
you're feeling inside,
it's probably not
as bad as you think.
And it's probably not
showing as much as you think.
You can't have
real conversations
without candor and honesty.
And that's the heart of
all good communication.
I'm George Stephanopoulos,
and this is MasterClass.